El propósito de este video es simplemente comenzar
a apreciar cuán vasto y enorme es el universo,
y francamente nuestros cerebros no lo pueden
comprender. Lo que veremos en este video es que ni
siquiera podemos captar cosas que son realmente
muy pequeñas en comparación con el tamaño del
universo. En realidad ni siquiera sabemos cuál
es el tamaño total del universo, pero dicho esto,
vamos a intentar apreciar lo pequeño que
somos. Este de aquí soy yo, mido 1 metro con 75
centímetros, dependiendo si calzo zapatos, tal vez
un 1.77 metros con zapatos. Pero para el propósito
de este video, vamos a aproximarlo a 2 metros.
Ahora bien, si tuviera que acostarme 10 veces,
una detrás de otra, obtendría aproximadamente
la longitud de un camión de 18 ruedas, esto es
aproximadamente 20 metros, así que multiplicamos
esto por 10. Ahora bien, si pudiéramos parar,
es decir, si pudiéramos poner de manera vertical
10 camiones de 18 ruedas uno encima de otro,
es decir, si lo multiplicamos por 10, obtendremos
aproximadamente la altura de un rascacielos de 60
pisos. Una vez más, si pudieras llevarme
y apilarme 100 veces uno encima de otro,
obtendrás aproximadamente la longitud de
un rascacielos de 60 pisos. Ahora bien,
si acuestas 10 rascacielos en línea, obtendrías
algo de la longitud del puente Golden Gate. Y no
estamos utilizando las medidas exactas, no es
que siempre sea exactamente por 10, pero es un
aproximado. Y tenemos algo cercano a 2 kilómetros,
el puente Golden Gate de hecho mide un poco más de
2 kilómetros. Pero si sólo medimos la estructura
colgante, son aproximadamente 2 kilómetros,
de hecho es un poco menor a 2 kilómetros. Ahora
bien, si multiplicamos esa distancia por 10
obtenemos el tamaño de una ciudad grande. Esta
es una fotografía satelital de San Francisco,
este es el puente Golden Gate, y lo que intenté
hacer al copiar y pegar esta fotografía fue
hacerla de aproximadamente 20 km por 20 km,
para que puedas apreciar la escala. Y esta
fotografía es interesante, ya que es la primera
vez que podemos relacionarnos con ciudades; pero
cuando miras una ciudad a esta escala, empieza a
hacerse más grande de lo que estamos acostumbrados
a procesar a diario. Es decir, un puente,
estuvimos en un puente, sabemos cómo es un puente,
sabemos que un puente es enorme, pero no parece
algo que no podamos comprender. Sin embargo,
una ciudad es algo que no podemos comprender de
una sola vez. Podemos conducir por una ciudad,
podemos mirar imágenes de satélite; pero si
tuviera que señalar a un ser humano en esta
imagen sería increíblemente pequeño, en realidad
no podríamos verlo, sería menor a un pixel de esta
imagen, de hecho una casa mide menos que un pixel
en esta imagen. Pero sigamos multiplicando por 10.
Si multiplicamos por 10 una vez más, llegamos
a algo del tamaño del área de la bahía de San
Francisco. Este cuadrado que tenemos aquí es
aproximadamente este cuadrado que señalaremos
por acá. Y ahora multipliquemos de nuevo por
10. Este cuadrado tiene 200 kilómetros por 200
kilómetros, y entonces este cuadrado tendrá 2,000
kilómetros por 2,000 kilómetros. Aquí incluimos
gran parte del oeste de los Estados Unidos:
tenemos por acá California, tenemos Nevada,
tenemos Arizona, Nuevo México. Entonces tenemos
incluido una gran parte de un gran continente,
y francamente esto está más allá de la escala que
estamos acostumbrados a operar. Hemos visto mapas
así que tal vez estemos un poco acostumbrados,
pero si alguna vez tuvieras que cruzar
caminando este tipo de distancia, te tomaría
bastante, bastante tiempo. Hasta cierto punto,
el hecho de que los aviones vayan tan rápido,
casi inimaginablemente rápido para nosotros,
nos da la sensación de que los continentes no
son tan grandes porque puedes cruzarlos en 5 o
6 horas. Pero estas son distancias muy, muy, muy
grandes, enormes. Y una vez más, si tomas este
cuadrado, que es aproximadamente 2,000 kilómetros
por 2,000 kilómetros y lo multiplicas por 10,
vamos a obtener un poco más que el diámetro de la
Tierra, un poco más que el diámetro de la Tierra.
Pero una vez más estamos en la Tierra. Podemos
relacionarnos con la Tierra. Si vemos el horizonte
con atención, veremos un poco la curvatura
de la Tierra, especialmente si estuviéramos
en un avión y, aunque francamente esto es más
grande de lo que mi cerebro puede comprender,
podemos establecer una comparación con la Tierra.
Pero si multiplicamos por 10 veces el diámetro de
la Tierra obtendremos aproximadamente el diámetro
de Júpiter. Entonces, si tuvieras que colocar la
Tierra junto a Júpiter, obviamente no está tan
cerca, ya que esto destruiría los dos planetas.
De hecho, definitivamente destruiría la Tierra,
probablemente simplemente se fusionaría con
Júpiter. Pero si colocamos la Tierra junto a
Júpiter, se vería algo así. Entonces, yo diría
que de este diagrama Júpiter definitivamente es lo
primero que mostramos que no puedo comprender. Es
decir, la Tierra en sí misma es realmente enorme,
pero Júpiter tiene 10 veces su diámetro, es mucho
más grande en términos de masa y volumen y todo lo
demás; pero si nos fijamos sólo en su diámetro, es
10 veces mayor que el diámetro de la Tierra. Pero
si multiplicamos el diámetro de Júpiter por 10 nos
da aproximadamente el diámetro del Sol. Así que
si queremos dibujar Júpiter a un lado del Sol se
vería justo así, mientras que la Tierra se vería
algo así. Si los pusiéramos a los tres juntos,
pero el Sol una vez más es enorme, aunque lo
veamos todos los días es inimaginablemente enorme,
la Tierra por sí misma es inimaginablemente
enorme, y el Sol tiene 100 veces el diámetro
de la Tierra. Ahora vamos a empezar a
enloquecer y mucho. Si el diámetro del Sol,
que ya es 100 veces el diámetro de la Tierra, lo
multiplicamos por 100, obtenemos la distancia de
la Tierra al Sol. Así que dibujé el Sol aquí
con un pequeño pixel y ni siquiera dibujé la
Tierra porque un pixel sería demasiado grande,
tendría que ser una centésima de pixel para
dibujarla correctamente. Así que esta distancia
entre la Tierra y el Sol es inimaginable,
es 100 veces el diámetro del Sol, así que
tenemos algo realmente masivo. Pero una vez más,
estas cosas están relativamente cerca comparadas
con lo que vamos a ver, porque si quisiéramos ir
a la estrella más cercana. Recuerda: el diámetro
del Sol es 100 veces el diámetro de la Tierra,
y a su vez la distancia entre el Sol y la
Tierra es 100 veces eso, o podríamos decir
que es 10,000 veces el diámetro de la Tierra,
son distancias inimaginables. La distancia a la
estrella más cercana que está a 4.2 años luz es
200,000 veces la distancia del Sol a la Tierra,
que, una vez más, esto es increíble. Y para darte
una idea aproximada de cuán alejadas están estas
cosas, si el Sol fuera aproximadamente
del tamaño de una pelota de baloncesto,
si la estrella promedio fuera del tamaño de
una pelota de baloncesto y nuestra parte de
la galaxia tuviera un volumen del tamaño de la
Tierra, es decir, si tuvieras un gran volumen
del tamaño de la Tierra, y si las estrellas fueran
del tamaño de una pelota de baloncesto, en nuestra
parte de la galaxia sólo tendríamos un puñado de
pelotas de baloncesto por ese volumen. Es decir,
están increíblemente dispersas, aunque cuando
miras la galaxia -y esto es sólo la representación
de un artista-, parece algo que tiene un rocío
de estrellas, y parece razonablemente denso;
pero en realidad tiene una gran cantidad de
espacio, es decir, la gran, gran, gran, gran,
gran parte del volumen en la galaxia sólo es
un espacio muy, muy vacío: no hay estrellas,
no hay planetas, nada. Es decir, esta distancia
de la que estamos hablando es un gran salto,
y luego, si realmente quieres darte cuenta
de qué tan grande puede ser una galaxia,
puedes tomar esta distancia entre el Sol o entre
nuestro Sistema Solar y la estrella más cercana
que es 200,000 veces la distancia entre la Tierra
y el Sol y multiplícala por 25,000. Entonces,
si el Sol está por aquí, nuestra estrella más
cercana estará en el mismo pixel, de hecho,
tendremos un montón de estrellas en un mismo pixel
a pesar de que estén tan separadas, y toda esta
galaxia mide 100,000 años luz, que es 25,000
veces la distancia entre el Sol y la estrella
más cercana. Así que ahora sí, estamos hablando
de distancias inimaginables, insondables, y sólo
en una galaxia. Francamente esto ya está más allá
de cualquier cosa que mi cerebro pueda procesar,
en este punto casi se convierte en un pensamiento
abstracto, simplemente se convierte en jugar con
números y matemáticas. Pero para obtener una idea
del universo completo, el universo observable;
y aquí hay que ser muy claros: sólo podemos ver
la luz emitida hace 13.7 miles de millones de
años luz, porque esa es la edad del universo. El
universo observable tiene aproximadamente 93,000
millones de años luz de diámetro, y la razón
por la que supera los 13.7 miles de millones
es porque los puntos en el espacio que emitieron
luz hace 13.7 miles de millones de años se han
alejado de nosotros, así que ahora están a unos
40,000 millones de años luz de distancia. Pero
no se trata de cosmología, este video trata
sólo de escalas y de apreciar lo enorme que
es el universo, y sólo en la parte del universo
que teóricamente podemos observar y que podemos
observar sólo porque estamos recibiendo radiación
electromagnética de esas partes del universo. Si
multiplicamos este número, vamos a hacerlo con
calma: 100,000 años luz, que es el diámetro de
la Vía Láctea, así que 100,000 años luz que
es el diámetro de la Vía Láctea tendremos que
multiplicarlo no por 1,000, si lo multiplicamos
por 1,000 nos daría 100 millones de años luz, sino
por otros 1,000 más para obtener 100,000 millones
de años luz. Y el universo, por lo que sabemos,
tal vez podría ser mucho, mucho, mucho, mucho,
mucho más grande, tal vez infinito. ¡Quién sabe!
Pero para pasar del diámetro de la Vía Láctea
al universo observable hay que multiplicarlo por
1 millón, y ésta ya es una distancia insondable.
Entonces, en todo el esquema de las cosas no sólo
somos muy pequeños, no sólo son bastante pequeñas
las cosas que construimos, no sólo nuestro planeta
es ultra pequeño, no sólo el Sol es ultra pequeño
y no sólo nuestro Sistema Solar es ultra pequeño,
sino que incluso nuestra galaxia no es nada
comparada a la inmensidad del universo.